the Black Hills is the beginning in the
origin of our people this is the heart
of Mother Earth it is our Mecca
it is our Vatican and without it our
ceremonies would not exist to the Lakota
we call it a Samba the heart of
everything that is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the United States there's many
different Native Nations and one of them
is referred to as the Sioux but we don't
use the word Sioux we go by our tribal
name of Lakota and lock what that means
friends and allies my name is Sequoia
Crosswhite I'm a musician
the cultural relations advisor and a
teacher my job is to educate people
about this area and about the history of
this area and to preserve the stories so
that we have it for the next generations
to come
my goal is to open people's minds about
the native population here in the Black
Hills by taking them on tours
the role of the storyteller is to teach
truth through stories and through myths
you're keeping that history alive every
time you tell that story to somebody new
without storytelling our culture and our
history could fade away and the south
west of the Black Hills you can find
petroglyphs that date back about 10,000
years if not older it's telling stories
of people's lives that live there at
that point in time so this is considered
the oldest petroglyph in all the United
States this is a hunting scene you have
a mountain lion in one corner and a
mountain lion in the other corner
they're kind of gathering in the herd of
elk beyond just the artifacts in the
petroglyphs the land formations and the
areas around the Black Hills are
significant to the Lakota people for
spiritual and historical values of where
the people existed and how they came to
be
it gives me an overwhelming feeling to
know that I'm walking in the same
footsteps of where my ancestors have
been and encourages me to become a
warrior to protect this place and to
ensure its existence for many
generations to come
[Music]
you